R
ME.
>> Tucker: BEYOND BELIEF.
THANKS FOR COMING.
A REALLY INTERESTING STORY.
5 DAYS AGO THE FAA ORDERED
A GROUND STOP ON ALL AIR TRAVEL
IN THE U.S.
NOT A SINGLE COMMERCIAL OR
PRIVATE AIRCRAFT WAS ALLOWED IN
THE SKIES.
THAT'S VERY SERIOUS.
THE ONLY OTHER TIME WE HAD THAT
WAS AFTER 9-1121 YEARS AGO.
IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
-- WHY DID THE GOVERNMENT GROUND
ALL THE PLIANCE?
PETE BUTTIGIEG WHO RUNS THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT AND
OVERSEES THE FAA SAID HE WAS NOT
SURE.
THEN OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL HOURS
A STORY EMERGED.
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEM THAT SEND
MESSAGES TO PILOTS HAD GONE
DOWN.
THEN THE EMERGENCY BACK UP
SYSTEM ALSO WENT DOWN.
THE FAA NOTICED THIS ON TUESDAY
NIGHT.
THE GOVERNMENT ISSUED A GROUND
STOP THE NEXT MORNING.
THAT'S WHAT PETE BUTTIGIEG SAID.
HE DESCRIBED THE CULPRIT AS
A DAMAGED DATABASE FILE WITH NO
EVIDENCE OF A CYBER ATTACK.
PETE BUTTIGIEG SAID THERE WAS NO
IT WAS JUST YOUR GARDEN VARIETY
SOFTWARE ERROR.
SHUTTING DOWN ALL COMMERCIAL AIR
TRAVEL IN THIS COUNTRY IS A VERY
SERIOUS THING TO DO.
U.S. AIRLINES AIR TRAVEL IS
ESSENTIAL AND DANGEROUS.
ONE DAY OUR SYSTEM SHUT DOWN FOR
NO REAL REASON.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE TELLING US?
YES, EXPLAINED PETE BUTTIGIEG
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
MOST PEOPLE SEEMED TO THINK
THIS.
WE WERE NOT CONVINCED.
THE NEXT DAY, LAST THURSDAY, THE
SAME THING HAPPENED THIS CANADA.
THAT WAS VERY STRANGE.
THE U.S. AND CANADA HAVE
SEPARATE AVIATION AUTHORITIES.
THEY ARE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
EACH COUNTRY USES ITS OWN
SOFTWARE TO ROUTE PLIANCE.
THE SYSTEMS ARE NOT LINKED TO
EACH OTHERS -- PLANES.
24 HOURS AFTER OUR SYSTEM WENT
DOWN, CANADA'S SYSTEM WENT DOWN
ALSO.
THE CANADIAN GOVERNMENT SAID ITS
SYSTEM EXPERIENCED AN OUTAGE.
WHAT ARE THE ODDS OF THAT?
ON NEW YEAR'S DAY SOMETHING
SIMILAR HAPPENED IN THE
PHILIPPINES.
ITS AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL SYSTEM
ALSO WENT DOWN.
NO AIRCRAFT WERE ALLOWED IN
THEIR AIR SPACE.
THOUSANDS OF FLIGHTS OVER ASIA
WERE REROUTED WHICH IS
EXPENSEIVER AND DANGEROUS.
-- EXPENSIVE AND DANGEROUS.
THEY SAID CALM DOWN, EVERYTHING
IS TINE.
IS EVERYTHING FINE?
OR IS IT POSSIBLE THAT SOMEBODY
IS HACKING INTO AVIATION SYSTEMS
AND HOLDING VARIOUS GOVERNMENTS
AROUND THE WORLD HOSTAGE UNTIL
THEY PAY A RANSOM?
WELL, YES, IT'S ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE SUMMER OF
2020, A MEDICAL SCHOOL PAID MORE
THAN A MILLION DOLLARS IN BIT
COIN TO GET ACCESS TO THEIR OWN
COMPUTERS WHEN WERE FROZEN BY
HACKERS, HELD UP FOR RANSOM.
WHAT IF PEOPLE JUST DID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO THE FAA?
THEN TO THE GOVERNMENT IN CANADA
AND THE GOVERNMENT IN THE
PHILIPPINES?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD
NEVER TELL US THAT.
THEY WOULD LIE ABOUT THAT LIKE
THEY LIE ABOUT EVERYTHING.
MAYOR PETE WOULD CLAIM IT WAS
A SOFTWARE GLITCH.
THEY WOULD NOT US TO KNOW THEY
ALLOWED A FOREIGN HOSTILE GROUP
TO TAKE CONTROL OF OUR FAA.
THE LIE COULD ONLY COVER SO MUCH
BECAUSE THERE WOULD BE SIGNS OF
IT.
ALMOST ALL RANSOMS ARE PAID IN
BIT COIN.
IN THE U.S. BOUGHT HUGE AMOUNTS
OF BIT COIN THE PRIZE WOULD
SURGE.
HAS THAT HAPPENED?
YES, IT HAPPENED.
SINCE THE GROUND STOP LAST
THURSDAY.
THE PRICE OF BIT COIN SHOT UP
20%.
IS THAT A COINCIDENCE?
WE ASK